En este vídeo vamos a agarrar experiencia
resolviendo ecuaciones radicales,
ecuaciones que incluyen raíces cuadradas
o inclusive raíces de orden superior,
pero también vamos a intentar entender,
un fenómeno interesante
que ocurre al resolver este tipo de ecuaciones,
déjame mostrarte de qué estoy hablando.
Supongamos que tenemos la ecuación,
raíz cuadrada de "x" es igual a 2 x menos 6.
Algo con lo que te encuentras
cuando resuelves este tipo de ecuaciones,
es que para iniciar,
se trata de despejar alguno de los radicales,
aquí sólo tenemos un radical,
raíz cuadrada de "x", que ya está despejado,
así es que,
una vez que despeja uno de los radicales,
entonces puedes elevar al cuadrado
ambos lados de la ecuación.
Elevemos al cuadrado entonces ambos lados de la ecuación.
Reescribamos la ecuación la voy a hacer paso a paso,
entonces tenemos,
la raíz cuadrada de "x" elevado al cuadrado, es igual a
"2x" menos 6 elevado al cuadrado
y elevado al cuadrado es una operación válida,
si esto es igual a esto,
entonces elevando al cuadrado esto,
es igual a elevar al cuadrado esto otro.
Vamos a hacer eso entonces,
si tomamos la raíz cuadrada de "x"
y luego elevamos al cuadrado, obtenemos,
"x"
y esto va a ser igual...
vamos a elevar el cuadro este término,
esto va a ser 2 x al cuadrado que es,
"4x" cuadrada...
4 x cuadrada...
estamos elevando al cuadrado,
tanto el 2 como el "x",
y eso le vamos a
restar el producto...
el doble producto de estos términos,
eso va a ser entonces
"2x" por -6 es "-12x" por 2 es "-24x"
y finalmente el cuadro de -6 que es más 36.
Si encuentras difícil de entender cómo pasamos,
de esto a esto, te sugiero que revises
multiplicación de polinomios,
en particular, multiplicación de binomios,
donde vas a recordar,
que para elevar al cuadro un binomio,
es el cuadrado de este primer término
menos 2 veces el producto del primero por el segundo,
en este caso es -2 por "12x",
que es igual a "24x",
y más el cuadrado del segundo, más 36.
así que ahora nuestra ecuación
se ha simplificado, por así decirlo,
a esta que tenemos aquí,
veamos qué sucede al restar
"x" ambos lados de la ecuación.
Restamos "x" aquí y restamos "x" acá,
tenemos "x" menos "x" es igual a 0
y esto va a ser igual a "4x" cuadrada menos
"25x" más 36.
Así es que la ecuación radical,
se ha simplificado a una ecuación estándar de segundo grado
y para no complicarnos buscando una factorización
o completando cuadrados,
usemos la fórmula cuadrática,
la fórmula cuadrática que nos da los valores de "x"
que son solución a esta ecuación,
es igual a "-b",
en este caso es menos -25, que sería 25 positivo más menos la raíz cuadrada de "b" al cuadrado,
que es -25 al cuadrado, 625,
-4 por "a" que es 4,
-4 por 4 y por "c" que es 36.
Y todo eso dividido entre "2a" que es 2 por 4 = 8.
Saquemos la calculadora entonces para encontrar,
este término,
veamos nuestra fiel calculadora,
tenemos que calcular 625 menos, 4 por 4 es 16...
menos 16,
por 36
esto va a ser igual a 49.
Muy bien es un cuadrado perfecto,
sabemos que la raíz de 49 es 7,
regresando entonces a la fórmula cuadrática,
esto de aquí entonces es igual a 49
y "x" va a ser igual a 25,
más menos la raíz de 49 que es 7
y eso dividido entre 8,
y nuestras dos soluciones son
"x" es igual a 25 más 7 = 32
32 octavos, que es igual a 4
y la otra "x..." déjame hacerlo con otro color...
la otra "x" que es igual a 25 menos 7
18 octavos y esto resulta,
8 cabe dos veces en 18
y sobran dos,
esto será igual a dos enteros, dos octavos,
o dos enteros un cuarto o 2.25.
He ahí las soluciones
y ahora te va mostrar algo muy interesante
que quizá te va a desconcertar
porque surge una contradicción,
y de hecho te voy a mostrar por qué surge esa contradicción.
Veamos si las soluciones que hemos obtenido realmente funcionan,
probemos primero x igual a 4,
entonces aquí tenemos,
la raíz cuadrada de 4
es igual a 2 por 4 menos 6...
la raíz cuadrada de
4 es igual a 2
y esto es igual a
2 por 4 = 8 menos 6.
¡Sí funciona!
2 es igual a 8 menos 6, esta solución es correcta,
probemos ahora la otra solución,
"x" igual a 2.25.
Tenemos del lado izquierdo
la raíz cuadrada de 2.25,
esto no me cabe aquí,
déjame hacer un poco más grande este símbolo...
2.25...
esto es igual a 2 x 2.25
menos 6,
ahora quizá no puedes calcular mentalmente
esta raíz cuadrada,
pero si consideras que la raíz de 225
es igual a 15,
entonces podrías deducir
que la raíz cuadrada de 2.25 es 1.5.
Veámoslo con la calculadora para cerciorarnos.
Entonces calculamos la raíz de 2.25
y es igual a 1.5,
tenemos entonces del lado izquierdo,
1.5, lo cual, de acuerdo con esto,
tiene que ser igual a 2 x 2.25,
4.5 menos 6,
ahora, ¿es esto correcto?
veamos que no
1.5 igual a 4.5 menos 6 es -1.5
esto es una contradicción, quiere decir que 2.25 no es una solución,
no cumple con la ecuación radical,
por lo cual se llama solución extraña,
decimos que 2.25
es una solución extraña.
Y aquí tenemos un enigma,
¿por qué surge esta solución extraña?
seguimos todo el proceso que se debe seguir,
aplicando la fórmula cuadrática obtuvimos 2.25
¿Dónde estuvo el problema?
Bueno, al sustituir 2.25,
tenemos una pista, pues obtuvimos aquí,
1.5 es igual a -1.5,
algo que hicimos nos dio la solución 2.25,
que no aplica en la ecuación radical original.
Tenemos otra pista,
probemos las soluciones en este paso,
si pruebas las soluciones en este paso,
vas a ver que de hecho ambas soluciones funcionan.
Te sugiero que lo hagas en un rato que tengas,
si pones la solución "x" igual a 2.25 aquí
vas a ver que funciona
y también si pones la solución "x" igual a 4,
vas a ver que funciona,
así es que ambas son soluciones válidas de esto...
ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación .
Así que algo pasó cuando elevamos al cuadrado,
que hizo la ecuación ligeramente distinta,
hay una muy pequeña diferencia entre esta ecuación...
y esta ecuación...
y la respuesta al enigma es hay dos maneras en que puedes ver esto,
para regresar de esta ecuación,
a esta otra,
hay que tomar la raíz cuadrada,
para ser más precisos, hay que tomar
la raíz cuadrada principal de ambos lados.
Nota que también puedes tomar,
la raíz negativa,
nota que aquí,
sólo estás tomando la raíz cuadrada principal,
en esta ecuación de aquí,
déjame precisar bien este punto.
Ya hemos establecido, que tanto la solución válida como la solución extraña, de la ecuación radical,
satisfacen esta ecuación que tenemos aquí,
aunque sólo la solución,
válida satisface la ecuación original.
Déjame escribir entonces la ecuación que
satisfacen ambas soluciones
porque éste es un dilema realmente interesante,
pues creo que te da una idea de lo que pasa
cuando tomas la raíz cuadrada principal
y el porqué al elevar al cuadrado ambos lados,
estás perdiendo o ganando,
según lo veas, algo de información.
Ahora esta ecuación que tenemos aquí...
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí
la podemos escribir como "x"
igual a "2x" menos 6 elevado al cuadrado,
ésta es una interpretación legítima
de esta ecuación que tenemos aquí,
pero hay otra interpretación,
que también es válida de esta ecuación.
Esta ecuación también la podemos escribir como
"x" es igual a -1,
por
"2x" menos 6 elevado al cuadrado,
estas dos ecuaciones de aquí son equivalentes,
pues aquí estamos elevando al cuadrado -1 que es igual a 1,
así es que estas dos ecuaciones
son ecuaciones equivalentes,
ahora si reescribimos esta de aquí,
distribuyendo el producto de -1,
la podemos escribir como
"-2x" más 6 al cuadrado
o lo que es lo mismo,
6 menos "2x" elevado al cuadrado.
Esto y esto son dos maneras de escribir
esta ecuación que tenemos acá arriba,
cuando elevamos al cuadrado la ecuación original...
cuando elevamos al cuadrado
la ecuación radical original,
supusimos que esta era
la única manera de interpretarlo,
pero ya vimos que aquí, hay otra manera de interpretar
esa ecuación elevada al cuadrado
así es que encontramos dos soluciones a esto,
pero sólo 4 satisface esta interpretación de aquí
y espero que entiendas lo que está sucediendo aquí,
cuando estamos resolviendo esta ecuación cuadrática,
estamos obteniendo ambas raíces,
aunque en la ecuación original, la ecuación radical,
solo estamos considerando la raíz cuadrada principal.
Otra manera de ver esto, vamos a reescribir la ecuación original...
déjame reescribir aquí la ecuación original.
Tenemos la raíz cuadrada de "x"
es igual a "2x" menos 6,
4 es una solución,
2.25 no es una solución,
2.25 hubiera sido una solución también,
si hubiéramos considerado que ambas
de las raíces cuadradas de "x"
son igual a "2x" menos 6.
Ahora si lo pruebas 2.25
es una solución válida de esta ecuación.
Tenemos que, menos la raíz de 2.25
es igual a 2 por 2.25 que es
4.5 menos 6...
-1.5 esto está correcto,
la solución positiva es cuando "x" es igual a 4,
así es que por eso obtenemos dos soluciones
y si elevas esto al cuadrado,
quizás esta es la manera más fácil de recordarlo,
si eleva esto al cuadrado y elevas esto al cuadrado,
obtienes esta ecuación que tiene ambas soluciones.
Ahora, todo esto puede parecerte confuso,
no es mi intención de ninguna manera confundirte,
la manera más simple de proceder
cuando estás resolviendo ecuaciones radicales...
despeja los radicales, eleva al cuadrado, resuelve las ecuaciones,
te puedes topar con más de una solución,
sustituye las soluciones en la ecuación original,
las soluciones que no la cumplan
son soluciones extrañas,
en este vídeo me he enfocado en el
por qué surgen las soluciones extrañas,
y espero haberte dado
un poco la intuición de que la
ecuación radical,
se refiere a la raíz cuadrada principal de "x",
si hubiéramos tomado en cuenta también
la raíz cuadrada negativa de "x",
la solución extraña es entonces válida.